[Music]
all right i'm dave rubin and welcome to
another friday panel extravaganza
today we're going to be discussing
school closures school choice
and homeschooling and joining me are the
director of school choice
at the reason foundation corey de
angelis
author actress and education activist
sam sorbo
and the director of outreach for
prageru's new prep
program jill simonian welcome to the
reuben report everybody
thank you thank you all right so we've
been connected for about 10 minutes and
we all just vented
about our feelings about lockdowns and
masks but we're going to focus
on education here and i realize that
we're all sort of in interesting
cities right now so jill i'm going to
start with you because you're
we're actually pretty close we're about
a mile away from each other you're here
in crazy los
angeles i'm not happy with it i don't
even have kids yet but i'm not happy
with the teachers union schools are
still not open
everyone's kind of freaking out what is
the state
of schools in l.a right now
okay so the state of schools in the la
area i
my full disclosure my kids are in a
public school
in a district that we specifically moved
to outside of the la area because the
schools were
top-notch years ago and the state is
crazy us parents are so angry
i have been angry our district and we're
we're not in la unified okay we're
in a what's known as a boutique school
district
that is very much has been in
partnership
open conversation wonderful relationship
with parents in the community
but it's all i hate to say this it's
gone to hell in a hand basket
the last year yeah
push-pull divisiveness i can't even
describe it
finally finally my two elementary sc
school
children are in school back
every day three hour hybrid scenario
uh since for the last few weeks
so progress but still very angry and
just
right and of course a lot of that has to
do with the unions we're going to get to
them in a little bit so from the city
that i'm stuck in to the state that i
want to live in
sam you are in florida look at you
look at you rubbing it in in sunny
florida
i said nothing i can just feel it i i
can just feel that thing from you
floridians now no
what's going on in florida because
desantis obviously has largely kept the
state open
yes and the schools are open and he
actually took school closures pretty
much off the table
so schools have been in session of
course i come to this from a completely
different standpoint i haven't been
my kids haven't been in schools in over
a decade i've been an advocate for
homeschooling
and i've written a few books about it
and you can go to samsurbo.com if you
want more information
and it's funny because dave i found
myself on the same side as the left
saying don't put kids back in school
keep them closed
um of course i say that somewhat
tongue-in-cheek but frankly
what we are teaching our students in
schools is progressivism is socialism is
marxism
and i don't i don't know if there's a
solution to that because it's ingrained
in the textbooks and
the teachers have been indoctrinated at
this point and so it's going to be very
difficult to
uh to withdraw from that mentality
especially for our youth and now we have
even further things coming down the pike
so there's a whole new
directive to basically turn our children
into social justice warriors to convince
them that they are the oppressed class
so that they uh fight against the um
the authorities and overturn the system
and mind you of course they're putting
this through without any plans for what
the new system would be the system that
might be better than
the european-centric uh white system
that's
that's uh that started this whole this
whole great experiment that we call the
united states of america it's
anti-american
and so um yeah that's that's pretty much
where i
am yeah you bring up a couple things
that i want to hit on throughout the
chat but this idea
of suddenly it's conservatives let's say
or basically anyone
right or non-woke trying to get all the
kids back to school but that's exactly
where they're learning all these bad
ideas is a really
a really strange tension right now uh
corey you've been
talking about school closures and
everything else for quite some time you
are in dc how's it going in the zombie
apocalypse of dc
are you in the caged up zone over there
yes i'm right in the middle of dc and
look the public schools out here spend
over 31 thousand dollars per job per
year
and i'd say the best solution to all
this uh mess is to let the money follow
the child
even if you don't give them the full
thirty one thousand dollars let's say
you give them twenty thousand dollars
they can afford a lot of private schools
for with that money
okay so i love the idea of funding
students
not the system uh but let's bring this
back to the unions for for just a second
i know you've been talking about this
for a while corey but
jill as someone that you teach educators
how to be better educators and you also
have your kids in
public school which is pretty rare for
you know successful people in in la area
they preach public schools but they all
send their kids to private schools
what do we do about the union situation
here because it seems like
they never are going to go back until
they get a list of demands
that have nothing to do with kovid at
this point as we're seeing it has much
more to do with
the new equity programs and everything
else my
little community was lift the veil and
really expose a lot of us parents who
were blind for a very very long time
and i raised my hand because i am
included in that group that was blind
uh it showed us the truth and it got us
angry
and it's required us to be very very
courageous uh
in addressing what is happening uh
you know without in a very unfiltered
way and it's gotten down and dirty and
ugly at a lot of the school board
meetings
but i think that that's where it starts
and
one thing that we're trying to do uh
here at prageru's new prep program
is among many things to give parents
courage
to start speaking up we cannot be quiet
anymore we need to start
speaking up holding the unions
accountable calling teachers out
individually who are the union leaders
who are pushing for these egregious
lockdowns or demands and whatever you
know whatever they're
we have to start speeding up and that's
what we've been doing on
my family you know and my community
members on a personal level
and we have seen i'm not going to say
anything is perfect
but we have seen certain
directives and goals slowed down
certain things that the union wanted
that we're pushing for
we've seen them see the army of parents
of all of us come out
and they've slowed down a little bit is
it going to work forever
i don't know but it starts with parents
speaking
up loud and not being ashamed of it so
sam
not only are you feeling good because
you live in florida but now that
like homeschooling has sort of gone
mainstream like
everyone's kind of talking about it now
um
you said you've been doing it for 10
years is that what you said yeah over a
decade yeah
over for over a decade can you tell us
like what got you
into it and are you kind of feeling like
yeah guys you're all late to the party
this is what you should have been doing
all along well i've been
i've been preaching this for for years
now but uh
i'm i'm thrilled that people are
starting to see the benefits of
home education and i i would prefer to
call it home education because
schooling is what happens in school and
you end up with people who cannot think
uh because they're not they're being
taught actually not to think
and i i say that for instance we didn't
ask the right questions when the
pandemic came down
we agreed with two weeks to flatten the
curve and then they changed it to
slow the spread and nobody asked the
question and the reason that they didn't
is because in school we learned that you
have to ask a quest you have to
ask permission before you ask a question
and
and it goes on and on from there so for
instance parents say
used to say to me i could never
homeschool i wouldn't know how
and my question was always did you
graduate high school and they would say
yes and i said but you feel inadequate
to teach a third grader
so since the definition of education
is basically learning something well
enough to teach it
perhaps you haven't been educated maybe
you've been schooled
and perhaps you should reconsider
whether you want to send your child into
the system that
you know turned out the likes of you and
so
you know this is sort of an ongoing
conversation
what's that they always take that well i
assume yeah
you know it's i i do it rhetorically and
maybe not so much
in person because i don't want to make
enemies but but frankly
people don't really understand anymore
in this nation
what education is and that's the sad
truth because education used to be
engaged in the pursuance of truth
and it is no longer and so we used to
pursue truth beauty and goodness
and now we are teaching children that
there are no such things
that truth is malleable beauty is simply
in the eye of the beholder
all evidence to the contrary because if
you look at a sunset
typically you say it's beautiful and if
you don't think a sunset is beautiful
there's something wrong with you
and not the sunset but now we're
teaching kids no no beauty is simply
in the eye of the beholder and um and
goodness well
that's on a sliding scale too some
things are good and you know
sometimes if you steal from somebody hey
the insurance
company is going to pay for it so it's
good i mean
we're we're really at that at that edge
now
and so yeah the homeschool movement has
grown and i'm very hopeful that people
will understand
that it's more about the relationship
between the child and the parent
and the relationship that the child has
to truth beauty and goodness
the main thrust of home education is
that we are teaching children
to teach themselves and that's a skill
that's a lifelong skill we are not
teaching that in schools
so and i do gotta go ahead
i was going to say i do want to jump in
because everything that sam said sam sam
you know that you're already one of my
unofficial mentors here
i listen to your words and i soak it all
up honey but
because it's it's it's smart and it's
truthful and it's exactly what so many
of us parents want
but i gotta ask and maybe this is the
naive part of me because my kids are
still so young but
isn't everything what you just said and
described all of those values that we
share isn't it worth
fighting for families
through our public schools to keep those
ideals in our public schools through our
children
through our parental involvement as much
as possible isn't it worth
fighting for that that's why i'm still
hanging on to this yeah okay my kids are
in school and it's public school and
there's problems and issues but
i'm gonna fight because it's worth
fighting for let me let me actually pose
that was exactly the question that i
wanted to
to ask corey because as the school
choice guy
i hear what sam's saying and it's like
how could
anyone send their kids to public school
and then i hear jill and she's doing it
and there's some
some pushback that's kind of working but
but what do you think about that
question and then i'll let sam
real quick on the homeschooling i just
want to point out the u.s census bureau
just released a report suggesting that
about 11
of households are now formally
homeschooling not pandemic schooling at
home
but unenrolling their kids and formally
homeschooling which is
essentially a tripling of it just a
couple of years ago so it's a huge spike
in homeschooling
but then i also want to respond to
jill's point and say
yes i think we should do both you should
push for reform in the traditional
system
i will say i think school choice or what
i call funding students as opposed to
institutions does both things at the
same time
because it provides that bottom-up
accountability for the public schools
to change their curriculums and to
change how they teach
and how effectively they teach students
and it incentivizes them to open their
doors for business
there's a recent report from brown
university a working paper out there
that just came out last year
finding that public school districts
with more
low-cost catholic schools in the area
were more likely to reopen their doors
for business which gives credibility to
the argument that competition
is a rising tide that lifts all boats
and in the school choice literature
there's about 27 studies 25 of those 27
studies
similarly find that school choice
competition leads to better
outcomes in the public schools so we
should expect
the the curriculums to change as a
result of the competition as well
and i will say it's it's a lot tougher
to get things done through the
democratic process
um because the unions are so powerful
and
the c and then the teachers might still
just do the same thing anyway and that
may take a long time a lot of families
don't have it
much longer and they want to have
choices now and i think that's why
so many states are pushing school choice
legislation right now about 30 states
have
introduced bills to fund students as
opposed to systems and about a third of
those states
have already passed at least one bill
out of at least one chamber so in a way
the teachers unions have kind of
overplayed their hand this year yeah
interesting so i want i want sam to jump
in on that question as well jill i'll
give you my answer
though which is one of the last things
that was allowing me to say oh
i still am an old school liberal was
that i
believed that there was some role in for
the public for you know for public
education the tax money should be used
for public education
i've really shifted into more of cory's
position on this which is fun students
not the institutions because i think and
i'm fairly so i don't want to put words
in sam's mouth but i think she's going
to agree with me
that the woke ideology is so pervasive
it is so in the system right now that
even if you get little wins at public
schools
they're only going to be little wins as
the tide just
just keeps going but but sam i do agree
no no no i do agree with that i do agree
with that
so let's just say you can have as corey
points out and i love
i love all of corey's points frankly and
i'm so heartened to hear
uh actual statistics i hadn't seen that
study yet
uh but i will say that um you can have
it both ways
you can join the school board run for
school board you can
try to hold the unions accountable but
also not sacrifice your children
to the wokeness beast that has invaded
our schools
and i would put to parents and and by
the way
let me just say i'm really sad to be the
one carrying this message
i do not relish my position here i just
know the things that i know
and i also want to say i don't blame
teachers
because i think teachers are trying to
do the best that they can in a system
that has now been
corrupted by an ideology that sought to
corrupt
okay but when you have a child
that i spoke to on the phone having been
given
a a poem that featured erotic
violent sexual imagery okay
and with no warning and she said she
felt violated
and yet because the parents are so sort
of beholden to this system of ed
and it's not education and it's not
working
and we are 27th in the world and and we
spend more than any other country except
switzerland on
each on our students and in and so it's
a broken system and we're just not
willing to admit that it's broken
you know then then then you come up
against what's it worth
how precious are your children and
that's really what it comes down to
because the problem is
when the child is exposed to some of the
information that is given out in in the
schools and it's in the textbooks it's
it's
and some of the teachers are boy there
was a teacher who read this poem to the
class
right um it's too late
that that young woman was already
violated it was too late
they raised a ruckus and they went to
the school board and they you know
demanded an apology
it's too late yes there are certain
things you can't unsee
so so there's a there's a choice to be
made
and i would sorry because i've been in
this for
long enough yes i was tremendously
insecure that's why my book is titled
the way it is
i was tremendously insecure when i
started and what i discovered is
it's not about me it doesn't really
matter how capable i
am in terms of what i know all i have to
do
is be the lead learner and show my child
that they can teach themselves anything
and i'm equipping them to handle the
world i'm
also showing them relationship and love
of truth beauty and goodness
which are the most important things
really and so we have to rethink the way
that we define the word education in
this nation because
as i pointed out in my second book which
is behind me
words for warriors they've redefined
education they've redefined the word
fascist
they've redefined all of these words and
so our thinking is wrong now
on many of these topics and we really
need to
refocus ourselves and repurpose
ourselves
to winning back our language and our
culture simultaneously
so corey i think that's pretty much what
you've been trying to do right
absolutely and sam i just want yeah that
all all great points i really like
the point that you made about this is
not about the employees in the system
it's not
a problem with them it's that there's a
messed up set of incentives that's
baked into that system which is leading
to schools to be closed for
in-person instruction for so long and
over time
if we look at the data the system hasn't
really rewarded teachers
appropriately if you look at between
since 1960 we've increased inflation
adjusted per pupil education
expenditures in the us
in their public schools by 280 percent
in real terms and between 1992 and 2014
a report has shown that we've increased
real pure people inflammation adjusted
education expenditures by about 27
percent
but real teacher salaries after
adjusting for inflation
over that same period it dropped by two
percent so
that's because it's a close system yeah
we're not allowing for the free market
it's very simple exactly and the
employer has very little incentive to
spend the money wisely and the best way
to spend that money wisely is to
allocate it towards the teachers doing
the work
in the classroom but so we're just
throwing more money at its
administrative loan
support staff so you don't support
diversity
uh administrators being hired instead of
paying teachers a little bit more
that's not really the way to go i mean
seriously
public schools can do what they want as
long as that's as a result of
the free choice of individuals choosing
their schools perhaps a certain type of
administrative role is okay i don't know
the perfect
amount of any type of administrator in
any given school
and that's the beauty of the free market
because none of us has that information
on the ground that individual families
have and that's a great argument
to fund the students as opposed to the
institutions and one more
point five studies exist on this topic
looking again at the
competitive effects of charter schools
or private schools on the public school
teacher salaries
all five of those studies that i've seen
on this topic find statistically
significant positive effects
of competition from private and charter
schools
on the public school teachers right
guess what because
how to spend it guess what common core
which was adopted
throughout the nation without being
tested never tested
actually ushers in this idea that there
shouldn't be competition
that was the whole premise of common
core is that if you go from one school
to a different school
the level will be the same common core
makes it all common
and what parent doesn't want their child
to be common i mean seriously it's baked
into the name
and yet everybody jumped on to the tune
of billions of dollars because let's
face it the education game the
school game in this nation is based on
dollars
not on results and so now we have a
nation
that where children are being dissuaded
from learning math
that's part of the common core agenda
and they're being dissuaded from reading
classic literature
and they're being basically they're
being shown pornography in schools it's
it's
running rampant now and i know that most
people say well my school's different
because i
i really like the teachers and i really
it's a cute little school and whatever
but you're asleep at the wheel if you're
not reading the books that your children
are being uh
are being assigned and if your child
comes home with math homework that you
can't do
your child thinks you're the stupid one
sam next thing you're gonna tell me the
two plus two doesn't equal five but
we'll we'll save that
for a different joke actually
i want to shift to something i i want to
just do two stats that my guys pulled up
for me here that sort of sits
right below all this because i think
it's it's really important to talk about
so
pediatric visitations for mental health
concerns are up 24
for 5 to 11 year olds and 31
for 12 to 17 year olds that's according
to the cdc
uh and one in four young adults exhibit
exhibited suicidal tendencies
during the lockdown also according to
the cdc um
everyone knows these stories i feel like
we've all heard them or directly
experienced them or whatever
now i know you mostly deal with
educators but obviously you have young
children
as well what are you seeing on that side
of this the
the results of these lockdowns
the results of these lockdowns is that
well i mean twofold just as you said
mental health issues are skyrocketing
and i'm not
here i just want to clarify i am not
here to protect
the public school system in any way the
whole system
is broken i fully agree with all of you
and that the system is broken uh
but but on the other side of all of this
is like i said this year the veil was
lifted
and for me personally my eyes were awake
i have been you know my kids are third
and fourth grade so they are very small
since the beginning
i have been reading they are coming home
with from school saying okay that's good
that's fine that's weird that's not good
hi teacher what the heck is this
speaking up on the other side of this we
need
to take dave going back to the
statistics about mental health
we need to as parents take all of this
information and studies and findings
that have come to light through this
horrible awful year and for lack of a
better word
ramrod it into the faces
and onto the desks and into the email
inboxes and in person if we're able to
ramrod it to the union leaders our
government officials
just as sam mentioned you know our
school boards i've shown up
last week two weeks ago i showed up at
my school board meeting the first time
they did it in person
i read off specific examples of
everything wrong that is happening they
cut my mic
off okay they cut my mic off i kept
talking
this is the type of cur it was a real
scene it was a lot of fun let me tell
you
but this is what we need to keep
doing yes pay attention to our kids
extra more so
over the top than we ever did and in
order to counter all of this
woke nonsense that is going on and all
of the devastating effects
with kids mental health it's devastating
it's crippling
we need to
and we need to counter all of it in
providing our kids
at home what they need in terms of
spiritual help mental health physical
help teaching our kids american values
to offset
all of this so sam on the mental health
side of this i feel like there's a lot
of people
probably watching this and i'm sure you
get this question all the time that a
certain amount of people are very open
to homeschooling right now that maybe
wouldn't have been a year ago
but they're concerned about the
socialization part that oh what do you
mean my kids are just going to stay at
home with each other all day they're not
going to have recess
they're not going to be you know joking
in the back of the class all of that
kind of stuff which is
related obviously to mental health as
well what do you say to parents about
that
so i know that there are some children
who are extreme extroverts who really
crave being in a classroom with 30
other children uh but i just love that
the
inevitably the conversation goes to
socialization and shouldn't our kids be
in school for socialization and of
course my answer is i'm sorry i thought
we were talking about education but
okay let's talk about that uh
homeschooled kids by and large are much
better socialized
than public school children because i
don't know how you would think that a
sixth grader would learn proper manners
and good etiquette from other sixth
graders but they don't
and so homeschooled kids tend to
associate with
children and adults of all ages and
therefore they are held accountable and
they learn how to behave
better in public now if you want to
argue that going to yale will get you
connections that you wouldn't get going
to john podunk university
i can't argue that but if it's but if
it's costing you eighty thousand dollars
a year and you're not actually getting
an education
i'm not sure that it's worth it so you
know
there there are a lot of ways to come at
that question of socialization
unfortunately i think it's an invalid
question
to the topic which is supposed to be
education now if you want to talk about
mental health
i wish our schools cared more about our
children
because the schools that aren't opening
aren't opening and
they seem and they seem to have less
care for the mental well-being of
children that they proclaim
are better served being in school
corey i feel like i feel like you could
go in a million directions there just a
little
yeah there's a lot of things i want to
say but um yeah i mean
with the whole socialization debate
about homeschooling it always assumes
that all forms of public school
socialization is pos
a positive right there's a lot of plenty
of negative
examples of socialization that occur in
public schools obedience training
fighting drugs gang activity there's
bullying
school you get to avoid a lot of the
negative forms of socialization as well
and capitalize on the positive forms
of socialization as determined by
best by the parents and i will say with
the school reopening debate
look there have been a lot of costs
associated with not giving the families
the choice
to have in-person instruction over the
past year you guys already hit on
mental health issues in the fifth
largest school district in the u.s clark
county public schools
student suicides over the past year have
already doubled
and so that's that's a huge statistic
and then there's also
a lot of other evidence of mental health
issues going on but then
the learning losses are huge as well if
you look at fairfax county public
schools in my area
the number of students that have the
proportion of students that have
failed two or more classes since the
previous year has increased by 83
percent
and that number has increased by 111
percent for special needs students
and similar numbers have been emerging
all across the country a nationwide
study by mckinsey and company
two of them actually have suggested that
students
all across the nation are losing months
and months of learning and the learning
losses are the worst for students of
color and students from
low-income families as well so this is
leading to inequities that were already
existing
in our public school system and and for
what there has
keeping the schools closed has not led
to substantial benefits in terms of
reducing spread of
the community spread or hospitalizations
of the
tons of evidence a review of 130
different studies just came out
by john bailey who's associated with the
american enterprise institute
and he published this through the center
for reinventing public education the
most
massive study on the topic review of the
literature
suggesting that schools can safely
reopen and that school reopenings are
not linked to
significant increases in community
transmission of the virus
look every single family should have
that choice of in person or not and look
the one
silver lining from all of this i think
is that families are fed up with it
and they're seeing all the nonsense
about teachers union officials
vacationing in puerto rico while
fighting against going
to work or sending their own kids to
in-person private schools and then
railing right opening their own schools
for work
and the public schools opening the same
school buildings for in-person
child care but not for learning and then
charging families out of pocket
families are seeing all of this and
they're rallying behind
uh school choice or what i call giving
the money to the family so they can
figure it out
well listen all three of you guys are
doing great work unfortunately we're out
of time but i'd love to have you back
because i just think that this topic
it's so important like if we're going to
fix any of this stuff and i guess if is
the operative word there
then it starts with education so we're
going to link to all your websites and
all that good stuff right down below
and i thank you guys for joining me and
have a great weekend
thank you thank you
all right a little something on
education people i hope you felt that
that was uh
enlightening and interesting and that
you learned a little something there i
thought this was a good
sort of uh threesome for a lack of a
better term because
corey obviously focuses on choice for
the most part
and well jill focuses on educating
educators about all of this and has her
kids in public school and sam of course
is doing the homeschool thing so i
thought it was a nice little
a nice little blend i hope you got a
little bit of information there
and uh man it's like this in some ways
this is the issue that before i said
something about how there's the mental
health issue
lies above all this and then there's
just the education thing that lies below
everything that we're doing right now
like if kids are not going to be taught
any of the proper things this is what
sam was talking about if they're not
going to be taught any of the proper
things and if 2 plus 2
isn't going to equal 4 anymore and truth
isn't going to be truthful
and there are no going to be no
empirically truthful
things well then man how are we going to
fix anything else so i hope
you got a little something out of this
uh have a great weekend everybody and
uh we're back at 11 a.m pacific on
monday